alors que la rentrée a à peine commencé
voilà que les hostilités reprennent de
la part de tf1 qui mécontente a décidé
de s'en prendre une nouvelle fois des
pmp
tout commence lundi alors que cyril et
les chroniqueurs décidé de faire le
débrief des émissions de vacances et
notamment l'émission district est
diffusée sur tf1 face aux audiences du
programme très compliqué l'équipe avait
décidé de ne pas enfoncer le clou
j'ai pas peur de le lire district ced
c'est cent fois mieux quoi les relances
pour conclure la séquence sur une note
humoristique syrie d les équipes ont
diffusé dans cette même émission une
parodie reprenant les codes du film
culte le professionnel avec jean paul
belmondo une parodie en forme de clin
d'oeil on va pas recoupé des fruits
comme ça en prime time sur tf1 nous a
fait plus de mal en trois semaines
qu'obama rochelle en 20 ans de carrière
une réaction virulente de la part de tf1
qui a déplu à de nombreux internautes
qui en appelle à la liberté d'expression
à la liberté de parodier et qui reproche
à tf1 sa volonté de censure un
communiqué des menaces qui paraissent
bien disproportionnée comparé à l'humour
enfantin de cette parodie
alors tf1 peut-elle censuré tnp
alors je donnerai mon avis après à petit
la vérité du ce que vous en pensez
chez vous aussi oui enfin je trouve que
un c'est c'est mal connaître parce que
plus ils vont faire ça et plus
bouillonnants m déjà ça c'est la fois
ils s'en foutent ensuite par rapport à
arthur c'est vrai que mondial s'est il
ya une petite guerre entre aux mureaux
j'en viens à me demander quand même que
arthur était associé avec avec ses fans
courbit avant un bon d'associer
maintenant c'est votre âge aussi alors
il n'y a pas une espèce 2 c'est pas de
transfert de passe-passe qui ce qui
semblait y avoir entre en trou mais il
est certain que tf1 qui s'en prend à ses
excuses au mas de s'éviter une petite
chaîne c'est jane voit là bas c'est une
très belle chair une très belle jade
mais c'est une petite servir on n'a pas
à rougir non on n'a pas à rougir mais
tf1 c'est la chaîne numéro un c'est
pourquoi les attaquer à ces 8es à vous
et en plus ce maître banide g dans la
boue parce que vous êtes à une ceinture
de bendjé mais moi je t'ai fin si
vraiment ça les met en rogne qui n'en
peuvent plus de vous c'est très simple
arrêté le combat des preuves à benji
addition des molles voilée à l'iran des
mollahs et on va les quatre comme
programme midi voilà j'ai pas mal de
choses ont enlevé tout lé programme
rendait des contrats à banide j ai fait
une vraie censure des comme ça peut-être
que vous arriverez à faire taire cyril
hanouna je ne sais pas challenge je vous
dire moi je trouve que la proportion
déjà des problèmes beaucoup plus
importants en ce moment et c'est vrai
que là c'est une parodie ya vraiment là
en plus on était vraiment hyper sympa et
émissions district dette on peut pas
dire les shérifs district z marche je
vais en va pas vrai c'est comme lego
masters je le dis lego basterds c'est
notre boîte de production on l'a dit
vous n'avez vu doivent juger j'étais
battu fédérer vous avez dit que ça ait
dégringolé en audience même moi je me
suis dit ils vont quand même fort mais
on est obligé de dire les choses oui ma
chance que tf1 n'a pas compris une chose
c'est que tpm pète une émission médias
c'est dans la distincts des missions de
critiquer l avons bien on prête pas ça
aussi ceux ci nous avait dit ça la
critique est en bien ou en mal et c'est
merci m6 de france 2 france 3 ou 7 de
ses 8 schemidt donc et si tf1 avait une
émission média ce qui n'est pas le cas
il se gênerait pas pour critiquer ces
8es ce serait normal et vous inquiétez
pas moi j'ai bossé à tf1 pendant
longtemps que en interne ils se gênent
pas pour défoncer pmp et l'émission de
win a d'ailleurs fait un f1 qui a acquis
interdit aux candidats
voilà de koh lanta de venir ici mais son
tour la belgique menacée pascal qui en
dehors de ça qu'est ce que tu fais moi
complètement stratégiquement comme il
n'y va jamais ils sont pas bons il
fallait rien dire mais oui c'est quand
on fait un truc qu'on la ramène ça fait
encore plus de ben laden viendra en
train d'en parler ça sur moi je voulais
après malheureusement pour distribuer
c'est de la simple et vérité ces cinq
trois et on descend en dessous des 3
mais voilà après le pourquoi du comment
on peut en parler de sa vie il n'est pas
mort dans la dans le truc et
heureusement je les aime tellement belle
voilà dans le professionnel mais c'est
de la paresse et des émissions de tf1
dont parle en bien maison de paille
assuré janet on le sait je pense que
c'est je pense que c'est plus une guerre
entre eux les moins entre vous et arthur
les fêtes de vieux scories du passé mais
nous tirons parce que bon on va pas se
mentir
si tf1 a fait ce communiqué il ya une
personne qui l'a demandé certes il veut
rappeler aux téléspectateurs que vous
étiez au départ un de ses stagiaires
arthur dont vous connaissez bien et
campus à un moment il vous a même collé
une émission face à la vôtre qui était
le 5 7 à la maison et sa grande amie de
joe hart s'est passé moi j'aime bien la
vérité ima et on dit et on était il il a
voulu re devenir pote avec moi il m'a
appelé on a des jeunes ensemble vous me
connaissez il donne beaucoup mais après
c'est vrai que j'ai voilà je vais dire
où aller où on efface tout ce qu'il peut
se passer avant pour par après et dans
mon dos je le dis voilà je dis la vérité
pourquoi dans mon dos il n'a jamais dit
il a fait une émission alors qu on était
potes il aurait pu m'appeler et me dire
oh là cyril je vais faire une émission
sur la télé avec mon producteur qu'il
est venu chercher tout ce temps post qui
l'a débauché pour aller chez lui et en
face de touche pas à mon pote voilà j'ai
pas trouvé ça hyper faire paix et depuis
ce jour là j'ai dit stop on arrête de se
parler terminez oncle autre débat là
dessus chacun fait sa vie alors après il
va dire que c'est vrai qu'il ya parfois
je vous dis moi et j'ai pas dit stop
comme ça c'est vrai que je les appelais
forcément vous me connaissez je suis un
film a commencé à me dire oui qu'est ce
qui se passe je n'ai pas bien tout de
suite au match et on va se voir il m'a
dit normand ça sert à rien et vous allez
faire plein de france à damas où les
faits a plein de voix parce que pascal
et je ne l'aï pas fait moi je suis un
mec dont ils s'envoient moi je ne fais
pas de coups en douce jamais vraiment
les chiriches vous jure je suis d'une
fidélité vous le savez benjamin fidélité
d'une loyauté
voilà je ne fais jamais de cons 12 mais
quand on essaie voilà de me faire des
ponts 12 jeudi vient on s'explique entre
autre homme
on se parle on essaie de se voir et
c'est vrai qu'il a jamais voulu voir
jamais voulu me rencontrer
donc voilà je revoyais des sms est
envoyé des petits messages et j'ai
essayé voilà je le taquine un peu mais
j'ai pas aimé voir ce qu'on peut faire
maintenant c'est du passé et arthur je
traite ses émissions comme je traite
toutes les émissions à temps et si
arthur fait un succès d'audience je vous
le jure que j'en parlerai cette émission
et je dirais arthur a cartonné six
districts z avait cartonné on l'a dit la
première j'ai dit qu'ils seraient dakar
tenez je vous ai même dit arrêtez de
critiquer ça a cartonné la première a
fait 5 millions donc voilà oui mais vous
avez dit que c'était même moins pire que
boyard le monde alors que fabien j'écris
moi c'est moi qui sait vous partager un
peu les mêmes amis c'est ça qui est
curieux gad elmaleh bouder sachez le
mais oui à mettre que j'adore mais après
c'est vrai que voilà c'est compliqué
mais voilà après c'est pas non plus un
truc très très grave
je vous dis la vérité c'est pas non plus
un truc il ya plus grave dans la vie
mais c'est vrai que moi j'aime la
loyauté j'aime les gens qui disent des
choses en face et voilà je préfère qu'on
dise des choses plutôt qu'on cache
l'échaudé combler face alors derrière je
pense qu'il est temps de passer à la
dernière partie de ces partis dans la
partie
oui j'aurais bien voulu rajouter je vais
faire un petit pas de côté
si vous me permettez là on a vu des
tweets mais il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
qui ont été choquées par la parodie on
trouvait ça violents qui ont trouvé ça
difficile
non mais moi j'en ai vu aussi sur
twitter je me disais ouais mal an et où
le mec il est alors une belle montre
évidemment n'est pas mort les jours dans
la scène malgré tout en me tire dans le
mur et il est exécuté
donc après tout mais bon on va couper
avoir la bien sûr voulais pas de ça
c'est quand même dans l'imaginaire
collectif en france d'un film culte
qu'on a sur tous
donc voilà après donc ça c'est la
première il ya ce dauphin dans le film
and il savoir ouais il ya une faute oui
jean paul belmondo moeurs et les audi va
les sauver mais finalement le
réalisateur a choisi la fin ou jean paul
meurent et moi à chaque fois je vous dis
il va monter dans l'hélico il va sauver
oui gérald ça c'est la première chose
ensuite on n'est pas égaux face à
l'humour face à la maladie est
effectivement peut-être après tout que
ça l'a blessé et qu'il a trouvé ça trop
mais je n'en sais rien en revanche trois
mois pour moi vu de l'extérieur et j'ai
pas les tenants et les aboutissants je
connais pas arthur je n'ai jamais vu
j'ai l'impression que c'est une sorte de
boubacar hills sauf que vous voulez être
bien booba et lui veut pas jouer à caris
c'est à dire qu'en fait dans ce
règlement de comptes comme ça un peu de
clages de provoc et tout ça lui n'est
pas il n'est pas dans ce game là il
n'est pas dans ceux dans ce dans ce
rapport là c'est cette impression il
n'est pas il n'est pas face à vous comme
peu voilà comme dans le dans le dans le
rap c'est cette impression là que j'ai
voilà et ensuite sur la parodie
non mais ça je sais pas si je peux le
dire et moi j'en voudrais pas le dire
allez moi je peux rentrer à l'ena n'est
pas le professeur non non c'est pas ça
c'est que je trouve que malgré tout on
fait aujourd'hui des parodies sur sur
des chaînes sur blessure et parfois les
légions sont sanctionnés et de manière
très très dur et donc voilà parfois
aussi nous on n'en parle pas voilà j'ai
rien compris mais maintenant voyons sur
le gibier aussi géraldine c'est que
healy rejet parodie la la la la la
réussite c'est 8 g parodier marlène
schiappa chez le coiffeur c'est pas pour
ça que la régie de ses mythes m'a envoyé
un communiqué man is here in situ refait
ça tu sors de ses huit ont eu lieu mais
parler de la scoumoune vous vous êtes
oui
lucia à sa décharge dérision quand à sa
décharge il est sous pression il a déjà
réalisé dessus mais il a il est en
guerre parce que s'il ya des tweets des
apparemment des faux tweets pour le
défoncer les son jeu donc il en guerre
en parallèle avec alp parce que il est
ce qu'il pense que c'est eux qui font
des fautes oui la bbc pourquoi c'est
complètement faux je vous dire non mais
oui oui je parle dans sa tête il a
beaucoup misé il a crié haut et fort que
c'est une grosse émission s'est jamais
arrivé en france cette façon là il voit
que les chiffres qui tombent blanc qu'il
est sous pression et un peu plus il
apparut dit elle arrive je pense je ne
sais pas si c'est c'est une histoire
personnelle je pense que tout simplement
il est sous grosse pression et il n'est
pas là et c'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'il attendait du coup ils crament oui
moi je mets renforcer le pack côtés de
géraldine parce que si la parodie avait
été ratée saurait aucune importance
misto que l'idée est astucieuse qu'elle
était bien mené jusqu'à terme et qu'elle
était effectivement une vraie vraie
parodies dont elle a eu un impact et
c'est pour ça sans doute qu'elles
avaient baissé c'est ma maison mulally
jc pape s'est pas fait méchamment
c'était parce que j'adore les oui et
c'est une quand on dit on continuera à
faire des parodies ni si c'est un espace
de liberté
touche pas à mon poste on continuera
parodier continuera à recevoir des gens
qui n'ont pas la parole ailleurs on
continuera à vous écouter les cherry et
je vous dis ici
ce qu'il ya c'est qu'à une bande c'est
une bande de gentils voilà nous on n'est
pas en train de faire des coups en douce
d'essayer de faire des coups derrière le
dos tout ça quand on a quelque chose à
dire on le dit devant les caméras ont
directement au téléphone ou par sms
et après on se lâche et puis après on
passe à autre chose nicolas pernikoff
lorsque je voulais juste dire c'est que
d'abord il a fait il a fait le choix de
faire un pari audacieux en lançant bien
sûr strict z l'émission elle s'est
plantée ça arrive ça m'est arrivé un
insecte the same à résidence et on l'a
déjà dit je ne souhaite ça à personne
même nous d'ailleurs bien sûr y démarrer
on s'est planté ensemble
maintenant je vois bien que il est
déstabilisé par une chose c'est qu'ils
répondent même directement aux critiques
sur twitter c'est ça c'est à dire ils
ont auparavant donné quelqu'un lui dit
oui il ya toujours les mêmes invités
dans l'émission il répond site et
programmateur tac à me proposer des
suggestions
donc je pense qui les sous-tend sûr déçu
c'est une chose très simple à une
affaire c'est qu'il a créé il a eu une
fortune avec stéphane courbit en créant
endemol ensemble à l'époque en france
qu'il a décidé ils ont décidé chacun de
leur côté d'ailleurs stéphane courbit
c'est quand même c'est pas mal écrasé
pendant des années en voulant recréer un
groupe est d'ailleurs il est arrivé
aujourd'hui puisqu'il est le délit de
de la ceinture mondiale vous êtes
administrateur vous êtes proche de
stéphane donc je pense aussi qu'il ya
une espèce de guerre d'ego mais ce
qu'est ce qui est normal parce que lui
était là il ya vingt ans et puis après
n'oubliez pas une chose quand même
arthur et 2 sur tf1 sur une chaîne dont
on parlait de la violence de la
télévision tout à l'heure vous savez
très bien qu'à la télé quand on
disparaît du jour au lendemain plus
personne n'oublie bondir quasiment bien
sûr lui se retrouve dans une situation
où il voit de tf1 qui changent tf1 qui
bouge des nouveaux animateurs qui arrive
lui qui est déstabilisée en ce moment
par ses mauvais scores de district z de
l'autre côté réussit aussi les choses me
rassure pas non plus dire soit que qui
foire tout je pense que ça ment il dans
un moment déstabilisation c'est un
moment où il voit là et je pense que il
à henry l'a un peu focaliser sur nous et
sur vous puisque en réalité mon la
parodie c'est une parodie on peut pas
robert sur la tmp d'avoir fait une
parodie mais de l'autre côté je suis
désolé sur dykstra z parce que moi aussi
on m'a appelé je suis désolé on n'a pas
été violent quand vous avez besoin la
vérité qui vous appelez on m'a appelé il
ya des gens du métier qui m'ont dit
qu'ils allaient très fort sur arthur
c'est pas moi je suis pas d'accord avec
ça je suis pas d'accord j'ai dit à un
moment donné quand on a parlé de
l'émission qu'elle risquait de perdre
parce que effectivement aller perdu 2
millions entre le début et la fin sur la
première que c'était quand même un très
mauvais signal et qu'on avait fait on
avait parlé ensemble et je crois que
vous avez 10 3 millions et demi ils sont
3 millions
voilà on en a parlé comme ça entre nous
en tant que passionné de la télé parce
que tous les gens qui sont autour cet
homme il aime la télévision ces cieux
mais pourquoi je ne suis pas en guerre
avec tf1 il ya plein de programmes que
j'adore sur tf1 koh lanta le jt jean luc
reichmann c'est un ami je l'adorent
jean-luc voilà c'est l'un des animateurs
préférés il le sait jean pierre foucault
miss france c'était formidable on l'a
dit donc on n'est pas en guerre contre
eux tu es pas on charrie aussi bien ses
8 m6 mme france télé bah voilà oui
bernard oui en tout cas je peux vous
dire n'être pas prêt de recevoir des
vedettes de tf1
moi j'ai zéro suspecte j'ai aussi se
fait ici dit qu'il voyait sofia de la
série là promet bien sûr formidable
qu'olivier marchal et justement j'ai dit
j'espère que vous viendrez me dit tu es
là elle n'est même pas question on en
parle même
pas mal oui ce que je trouve dommage
c'est qu'arthur c'est un animateur de
divertissement qui fait des vannes à
l'antenne et ses acquis à l'humour et
d'excès sur lui que c'est sur ces
audiences
il a plus aucun humour vous vous étiez
le premier hier vous venez sur les
audiences de cover je me rappelle un
moment il y avait des mines de charlie
hebdo sur vous qui était une violence
inouïe vous en rigoliez à l'antenne lui
d'excès sur lui on parle de ses
mauvaises audiences lui ils appellent ça
du harcèlement et de l'acharnement
mais désolé mais ce que ces millions 7
en prime sur tf1 pendant six jours à un
bon score tu es de l'est je vais vous
dire aujourd'hui moderne et un truc
aussi qui me dérange c'est que je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué on a eu et je
le dis aux téléspectateurs on a eu un
début de saison peu compliqué parce
qu'on avait changé beaucoup de choses
ont été à 700 milles mais vous faites
des vannes l'intérieur je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais maintenant qu'on
est entrain millions 3,1 millions 5 avec
l'ia encore une pointe à 1 million by
les emmerdes reviennent au togo comme
par hasard est de plus en plus et on
nous attaque pourquoi nicolas c'est
normal ça va mal tout simplement parce
que vous remontez car effectivement vous
avez fait une pointe à 1 million 8 et
que vous revenez à nouveau quelqu'un
parce que chaque fois que vous repartez
en début de saison il ya toujours ces
mauvaises langues qui disent oh la la
c'est l'année trop si la dernière année
c'est fini encore y'a pas longtemps on
parlait du renouvellement de votre
contrat dans la certaine presse un peu à
scandale voilà on est revenus là dessus
et maintenant mais forcément vous allez
montez donc forcément va s'en prendre
plein voilà ce qu'est ce que ça vous a
ajouté la radio
de même de faire des communiqués de
presse pour vous répondre ça parle de
harcèlement par non car tu ris défendent
c'est normal non se fait attaquer angers
la toile avec plaisir voilà si je vais
vous faites attaquer cyril vous allez me
dire vous allez voudra chante parodique
mais là de faire des cauchemars et la
chaîne je vous dis moi si quelqu'un
m'avait appelée c8 pour leur dire vous
fait la qualité pour vos défenses et
cissé lui caressa c'est le cas là mais
en toi c'est peut-être bien sûr des
communiqués sur maui veut la peau d'âne
ou n'at il faut le banc lyonnais il faut
plus aller dans ces émissions ça par
contre c'est un peu trop qu'on se
défende sur twitter oui mais après de la
faire des communiqués c'est peut-être un
petit peu dirigeants est un jour
important dossier qu'il faut dire et qui
gênent énormément c'est que vous avez
quand même un public d'une fidélité
c'est vrai merci à vue 5 millions plus 2
5 millions sur twitter
et ce sont les gens qui sont d'une
finesse et bagram et moi plus sa séance
que ça dérange à dire merci à vous c'est
vrai que c'est pas de chez vous
c'est vous qui énervait vous êtes trop
fidèle et je vous aime et vous savez
voilà je vous laisserai jamais delphine
toi qui est un peu en dehors de ça aussi
c'est vrai ben oui enfin je trouve que
c'est un peu le jeu du chat et de la
souris
je pense que réciproquement peut-être
vous voulez pas vous l'avouer tous les
deux vous avez un sentiment de les
consoles haine et admiration parce que
quelque part vous allez même parcours
vous voulez faire la même chose je vais
vous voulez toujours attendre quelque
chose si je vous racontais un truc et je
le raconte téléspectateurs et on a on a
des amis en commun avec arthur et mes
amis forcément beau raconte et il paraît
qu'à chaque fois qu'il fait une émission
il les appelle le matin il leur dit
cyril et a dit quelque chose il a fait
l'émission hannah il y avait l'habitude
il a regardé il a dit quoi
il a fait quoi c'est vrai que oui voilà
cellulaire des mines de rien beaucoup
d'énergie à devoir et ont regardé à vous
scrutez comme ça quelque part c'est pas
très cher plus graves
voilà j'espère vraiment pour vous 2 que
vous trouverez un jour un terrain
d'entente parce que comme vous dites
depuis des années cyril la télé c'est
qu'elle soit évidemment non mais moi je
pense que chacun fait sa vie voilà pour
l'instant et puis a pas de guerre et
franchement tf1 on n'est pas du tout en
guerre avec vous sachez le et je vous le
dis chaque soit on dit beaucoup de bien
des émissions de tf1 et on peut dire du
mal des émissions de tf1 des malles des
émissions de ces villes du mal de la
régie de ses huit de marlène schiappa du
bien de marlène schiappa du bien de cas
benjamin castaldi et de ces mariages ou
encore de la coiffure de guerre où je
voulais dire ça le rendrait beaucoup
plus sympathique de faire part en plus
une vanne sur son twitter sur les
audiences de ses émissions ça le
rendrait sympathique de reconnaître que
ça marche pas très bien et je me demande
si fait passable de parler d'acharnement
de harcèlement etc
on essaie d'aller négocier une saison 2
auprès tf1 mais si on m'a dit ils disent
qu'ils sont victimes de harcèlement etc
et ça a fait pour dire et vous ne signez
pas ça va faire le jeu intentions énorme
enjeu sur la saison 2 parce qu'on
rappelle que district z c'est un
problème qui a coûté très cher qui
veulent absolument le vendre à
l'international ci a pas de saison 2
c'est compliqué à vendre à
l'international
on peut imaginer que tf1 aussi des
intérêts dans cette saison de ça se fait
maintenant avec les chaînes donc je
demande si c'est pas un peu ça très bien
bas merci en tout cas la barre ajoutant
qu'à voir la question qui la police
comprenez vous la réaction de tf1 puis
32% nous à 60 % quand même 32% dire
aussi qu'ils la comprennent donc voilà